so we've been discussing similarities
regularity lemma for the past couple of
lectures and one of the theorems that we
proved was Ross theorem which tells us
how large can a subset of 1 to M be if
it has no three term arithmetic
progressions and I mentioned at the end
of last time that we can construct
fairly large subsets of 1 to N without
three term automatic progressions I want
to begin today's lecture worth showing
you that example showing that
construction but first let's try to do
something that is somewhat more naive
some more more straightforward to try to
just construct greedily
383 steps and recall from last time we
showed Ross theorem that such a set must
have size not all of em ok so what's one
thing you might do well you can try to
greedily construct such a set it will
just make our life a little bit easier
if we start with 0 instead of 1 so now
you put one element in and you keep
putting in the next integer as long as
it doesn't create a three-term
arithmetic progression ok so you keep
doing this well you can put two in so
let's skip to so we go to the next one 3
okay so four is okay so skip 5 we have
to skip 6 as well because 0 3 6 that's a
380
keep going so what's the next number we
can put in
go to nine okay then the next one is ten
okay what's the next one we can put him
okay so you can play this game right so
find out what is the next number that
you can put in greedily if you can put
it in put it in in a way that generates
a subset of integers without three term
arithmetic progressions so this section
has a name so this is called a Stanley
sequence and there's an easier way to
see what the sequence is namely if you
write the sequence in page three you
find that these numbers are 0 0 1 1 0 1
1 1 0 0 1 0 1 1 1 0 so these are just
numbers whose phase 3 representation
consists of zeros and ones
ok so I'll leave it to you as an
exercise to figure out why this is the
case if you generate the sequence greedy
list greedily this way this is exactly
the sequence that you obtain but once
you know that it's not too hard to find
out how many numbers you generate so up
to suppose n is equal to 3 to the K we
get 2 to the K terms which gives you n
raised to the power of log base 3 of 2
so you can figure out what that number
is but some number is strictly less than
1
and actually for a very long time people
thought this was the best construction
so this construction was known even
before Stanley if there was something
that it's very natural to come up with
and it was somewhat of a surprise when
in the 40s it was discovered that you
can create much larger subsets or the
positive integers without arithmetic
progressions so that's the first thing I
want to show you today so these sets
were first discovered by Salem and
Spencer back in the 40s and a few years
later a parent gave a somewhat improved
and simplified version of the Salem
Spencer construction so these were all
back in the 40s so these days we usually
refer at least in the additive
combinatorics community to this
construction as parens construction in
this indeed what I will show you is due
to parent but somehow the Salem Spencer
name has been forgotten and I just want
to point out that it was Salem and
Spencer who first demonstrated that
there exists a subset of 1 to n that is
3 AP free and has size and to the one -
little one that there's no power saving
so there exists examples with no power
saving and and this is important because
as we saw last time the proof of roster
I mean we basically spend two full
lectures proving Ross theorem and it's
someone involved right it wasn't this
one line of inequality you can just use
to deduce the result and that is part of
the difficulty so having such an example
is indication that graph theorem should
not be so easy it's not a rigorous
demonstration but it's some indication
of the difficulty of Ross theorem
okay so let's see this construction due
to parent so let me write down the
precise statement there exists a
constant C such that there exists a
subset of 1 through n that is 3 AP free
and has size at least n times e to the
minus c root log n perhaps somewhat
amazingly enough this bound is still the
current best known we do not know any
constructions that is essentially better
than barons construction from the 40's
there were some small recent
improvements that clarified what the C
could be but in this form we do not know
anything better than what was known back
in the 40s and the construction I will
show you hopefully it's you should
believe that it's quite simple so I'll
show you what the construction is it's
clever but it's not complicated and it's
a really interesting direction to figure
out is this really the best construction
out there can you do better
so let's see we're going to set some
parameters to be decided later mnd let
me consider X to be this discrete box in
P dimensions so this is the the box of
lattice points in D dimensions 1 through
m raised to D and let me consider a
intersection of this box by a sphere of
radius root L we look at points in this
X such that the sum of their squares is
equal to exactly L you take a bunch of
these spheres they partition your set X
smallest possible sum of squares largest
possible sum of squares so in particular
there exists some L such that X sub L is
large
just by pigeonhole principle you can
probably do this step a little with a
bit more finesse but it's not going to
change any of the asymptotics okay the
intuition here and we'll come back to
this in a second is that X lies XL lies
on a sphere so this is the set of
lattice points that lies on a given
sphere and because you are looking at a
sphere it has no three term a piece so
we're going to use that property but
right now it's not yet a subset of the
integers so what we're going to do is to
take this section of a sphere and I'm
projected through one dimension so that
it is now going to be a sub set of
integers
and we're going to do this in such a way
that it does not affect the presence of
three-term LPS so let us map X to the
integers by base expansion so this is
base 2m expansion all right so what's
the point of this construction here so
far
well you verify a couple of properties
the first thing that this construction
here is injective this map so if you
call this map think of this fee is
injective or space expansion so it's
it's injective but also somewhat
stronger claim is that if you have three
points so if you have three points in X
that map to a three ap in integers then
the three points originally must be a
three ap in X okay this is not a hard
time just think about it here because
we're using to base to M expansion and
you only allowed to use digits up to M
you don't have any wraparound effects
you don't have any carry overs when you
do the addition so combining these two
observations
[Applause]
we find that the image of Excel is a CA
P 3 set 1 2 and okay so one is and I can
take em to be for instance to M raised
to power D so all the numbers up there
are less than this quantity and the size
is the size of except L which is M to
the D divided by D M squared and now you
just need to find the appropriate
choices of the parameters m and D to
maximize the size of XML and and that's
that's an exercise and so for instance
if you take M to be e to the root log N
and D to be good log n then you find
that the size here is the bound that we
claim and that finishes the construction
of parent giving you a fairly large
subset of 1 through n without three term
arithmetic progressions and the idea
here is you look at a higher dimensional
object namely a higher dimensional
sphere which has this property of being
383 and are you projected onto the
integers any questions so far
okay so we have some proof do we have
some examples so now let's go on to
variations of Ross theorem and I want to
show you a higher dimensional version of
Ross theorem so I mentioned in very
first lecture so you have this whole
host of theorems in additive
combinatorics rough
similarly multi-dimensional similarity
okay so this is in some sense the
simplest example of multi-dimensional
similarity theorem and this example is
known as corners okay so what's a corner
a corner is what we're working inside
two dimensions so Corner is simply three
points such that the two throat their
position like that such that these two
segments they are parallel to the axis
and they are the same length okay so
that's by definition where the corner is
and the question is if you give me a
subset of a grid that is Corner free how
large can this subset theorem so if a is
a subset of 1 to M with no corners
particular no three points of the form X
comma Y X plus T comma Y and X comma y
plus D where D is some positive integer
then the size of a has to be little o of
N squared question
okay good question so that's one of the
first things we will address in this
proof so your question was do we only
care about corners oriented in the
positive direction so you can have a
more relaxed version of this problem
where you allow D to be negative as well
I look the first step in the proof is so
we'll see that that constraint doesn't
actually matter yes okay great let's get
started so as Michael mentioned we do
have this constraint in this over here
that D is positive and somewhat annoying
because if you remember in our proof of
Ross theorem they are positive negative
they don't play a role so let's try to
find a way to get rid of this constraint
so that we are in a more flexible
situation all right so first step is
that well get rid of this D being
positive requirement okay so here is a
trick let's consider the sum set a plus
a okay so some set here means and
looking at all pairwise sums as a set so
you don't keep track of you don't keep
track of duplicates all right so you
keep it as a set and we're living inside
the squid but now somewhat wider and
with okay
then there exists a element in this
domain of the subset by pigeonhole
that's represented in many different
ways so there exists a Z represented as
a plus B in at least size of a squared
divided by size of 2n squared
different ways just because if you look
at how many things come up in that
representation okay just use pigeonhole
and now let's take a prime to be a
intersect Z minus a alright so what's
happening here so you have this set a
and basically what I want to do is look
at the look at minus a and then shift
minus a over so that the intersect in as
many elements as you can and by
pigeonhole I can guarantee that their
intersection is fairly large because
size of a prime is essentially the
number of ways that Z can be represented
in the aforementioned manner so it's the
physis to show that a prime yes and
squared if you show that and you
automatically show a lot o of N squared
but now a prime is symmetric it's a
prime is symmetric around Z over 2
so this is centrally symmetric about 0 /
2 meaning that a prime equals to Z minus
a prime and so you see now we've gotten
rid of this deep positive requirement
because if a prime had a positive corner
then has a negative corner and vice
versa so no corner in a prime with the
positive implies that no corner with be
negative okay so now let's forget about
a and a prime and just replace a by a
prime and forget about this the positive
condition so let's forget about this
part and but I do want B not equal to 0
otherwise you have trivial corners of
course you always have trivial corners
all right
so remember how the proof of Ross
theorem went and this relates to the
very first lecture where I show you this
connection between additive
combinatorics on one hand and graph
theory on the other hand or you take
some arithmetic pattern and you try to
encode it in a graph so that the
patterns in your automatic set
correspond to patterns in the graph so
we're going to do the same thing here so
we're going to encode the subset of the
grid as a tripartite graph in such a way
that the corners correspond to triangles
in the graph
okay so I'll show you how to do this and
it will be fairly simple but and in
general I mean sometimes it takes a
little bit ingenuity to figure out what
is the right way to set up the graph so
one of an upcoming homework problem will
be for you to figure out how to set up a
corresponding graph when the pattern is
not a corner but a square right if I add
one extra point up there how would you
do that
so okay okay so what does this graph
look like
let's build a graph where so this should
be somewhat reminiscent of the proof of
Ross theorem where I give you three sets
XY and z and x and y are both going to
have n elements and Z is now going to
have two n elements
X they're supposed to enumerate or index
all the vertical lines in your grid so
you have this grid n by n so exercise
for each vertex in X corresponds to a
vertical line y corresponds to the
horizontal lines and thee corresponds to
these negatively sloped diagonal lines
slope -1 lines of course you should only
take lines that affect you are n by n
grid so that's why there there's many of
them for each direction okay so what's
the graph I join two vertices if there
are corresponding lines meet in a point
of it
so I might have this might be a a point
of a so I put an edge between those two
lines 1/4 X 1/4 Z because the
intersection lies in a and more
explicitly I mean that is pretty
explicit and alternatively you could
also write this graph by telling us how
to put in the edge between X and Z
namely you do this if X comma Z minus X
nicing a you put an edge between x and y
if X comma Y lies in a and likewise
you're putting final edge if Z minus y
comma y lies in a so to equivalent
descriptions of the same graph any
questions all right
so the rest of the proof is more or less
the same as the proof of Ross theorem we
saw last time so we need to figure out
how many edges are there every element
of a gives you 3 edges that's one of you
I just correspond the element the other
two pairs or two other edges and most
importantly the triangles in this graph
I claimed correspond to corners so what
is the triangle a triangle corresponds
to a horizontal line a vertical line
slope one minus one line that pairwise
intersect in elements of a if you look
at their intersections that's a corner
if you have a corner you build a
triangle and because your graph your set
is corner free well you don't have any
triangles actually no that's not true
right so like we saw in rostrum you have
some triangles but corresponding to
trivial corners triangles correspond to
trivial corners because you're set a is
tri this corner free trivial corners
meaning the same point with D equals to
zero so it's not a genuine corner like
that and in particular in this in this
graph every edge is in a unique triangle
and so we're in the same situation by
the corollary of of triangle removal
lemma we find that a number of edges
must be due to all of the number of
vertices so so the number of edges must
be sub-quadratic so must be little o of
N squared and so that implies that the
size of a is little o of N squared that
proves the corners theorem any questions
so once you set up this graph the rest
is the same as trois theorem so this
connection between graph theory and
additive combinatorics well you need to
figure out how to set up this graph and
then sometimes it's clear but sometimes
you have to you know really think hard
about how to do this all right
what does Corner have to deal with
roster them other than that they have
very similar-looking proofs you can
deduce roster and form the corners
theorem and two to show you this
precisely
so let me use R sub three of em to
denote the size largest and okay so this
notation R sub three is actually fairly
standard the next one's not so standard
but let's just do that so that's not an
L but that's a corner so that is the
size of the largest corner free subset
off and squared okay so we gave bounds
for both quantities but they are
actually related to each other through
this fairly simple proposition that if
you have an upper bound for corners then
you have an upper bound for Ross theorem
indeed given a a 383 subset of one
through n let me build for you a corner
free subset of the grid that is a fairly
large subset of that grid I can form B
by setting it to be the set of pairs
inside the squid whose difference X
minus y lies in a so what does this look
like this is the grid of size 2n and if
I start with a that is 3 AP free what I
can do so over here is look at the lines
like that putting all of those points
and you see that this set of points
should not have any corners right
because if they had corners then the
corners would project down to a 3 AP so
B is corner free
to recap if we have upper bound on
corners we have upper bound on Ross
theorem but you also know that if you
have lower bound on Ross theorem then
you have lower bound on quarters so the
parent construction we saw at the
beginning of today extends to exactly
this way to a fairly large corner free
subset and that's more or less the best
thing that we know how to do in fact
there aren't that many constructions in
additive combinatorics that's know
almost everything that I know how to
construct is fairly large come from
barons construction or some variant of
barons construction so it looks pretty
simple comes from the 40s yeah we don't
really have too many new ideas besides
playing and massaging barons
construction let me tell you what is the
best don't upper bound on the corners
theorem cut off so the proof using
triangle removal memo it goes to
similarities regularity lemma gives you
pretty horrible bounce but you saying
for you analytic methods so you see if
you have upper bound on Roth it doesn't
give you an upper bound on Raw on corner
so you need to do something extra and so
the best-known bound so far is of the
form and square divided by poly log log
M log log n raised to some small
constant C any questions
last time we discussed the triangle
counting lemma and a triangle removal
lemma and well it shouldn't be surprise
to you that if you can do it for
triangles we may be able able to do it
for other sub graphs so that's the next
thing I want to discuss how to use the
generalize the techniques and results
that we obtain for triangles to other
graphs and what are some of the
implications if you combine it with
similarities regularity lemma so let's
generalize triangle so the strategy for
the triangle counting lemma let me
remind you was that we embedded the
vertices one by one putting a vertex and
a typical vertex here should have many
neighbors to both vertex s so these two
guys should have sizes typically roughly
the same as a fraction of them
corresponding to the edge density
between the vertex parts and if they're
not too small then from the epsilon
regularity of these two sets you can
reduce the number of edges between them
so that was the strategy for the
triangle counting them so you can try to
extend the same strategy for other
graphs so let me show you how this would
have been done but I don't want to give
too many details because it does get
somewhat hairy if you try to execute it
so the first strategy is to embed the
vertices of H one at a time so my H now
is going to be lets say a k4 and I wish
to embed this H in the setting where you
have these four parts in a regularity
partition and they're pairwise Epsilon
regular with edge densities that are not
too small
well what you can try to do mimicking
the strategy over there is to first find
a typical image for the top vertex and a
typical image over here - some small bad
exceptions will have many neighbors to
each of the three parts next I need to
figure out where this vertex can go I'm
going to embed this vertex somewhere
here again a typical place for this
vertex modulo some small fraction which
I'm going to throw away so now you see
you need somewhat stronger hypotheses on
the epsilon regularity but they're still
all polynomial dependent so it's just
have to choose your parameters correctly
so this typical green vertex should have
lots of neighbors over here so you just
keep embedding so it's almost this
greedy strategy you keep embedding each
vertex but you have to guarantee that
there are still lots of options left
so embed vertices one at a time and I
want you embed each vertex so that you
have to be embedded vertices have many
choices left
so epsilon regularity guarantee so you
can always do this and you do this all
the way until the end and you arrive
some statement and depending on how you
do this the exact formulation of the
statement will be somewhat different but
let me give you one statement which we
will not prove but you can deduce using
this strategy and this is known as a
graph embedding them up and again as I
mentioned when I started discussing
similarities regularity lemma the exact
statements are not they're fairly robust
and they're not as important as the
spirit of the ideas or so if you have
some application in mind you might have
to go into the proof tweak a thing here
and there but you get what you want so
the graph embedding lemma says for
example that if H is bipartite and with
maximum degree at most Delta so the H
maximum degree is at most Delta and
suppose you have vertex sets v1 through
the R such that each vertex set is not
too small
and if these vertex sets are pairwise
Epsilon regular and the density is not
too small so here on doing assuming some
lower bound on the density which depends
on your epsilon then the conclusion is
that G contains a copy of H okay just
want to give a few remarks on the
statement of this theorem again we will
not discuss the proof so what does this
hypothesis our hypothesis on G being H
being our part I'd have to do with
anything so here as an example when R
equals to 4 instead of this k4 maybe I
also care about that graph over there
right or maybe some more vertices some
more edges but if it's for Park height
and the point is that I want to embed
the vertices in such a way that that top
vertex goes to the part that it's
supposed to go into that's what I'm
embedding this configuration you know in
the same way that corresponds to the
proper coloring of H okay so if you do
this you can there's enough room still
to go as long as you're have some lower
bound on the edge density between the
individual parts and you only depend
really on not the number of edges of H
but the maximum degree because if you
look at how many times each vertex its
possibilities can be shrunk it's at most
Delta times you know this graphing
bending lemma so I give you the
statement here but it's a fairly robust
statement and if you want to get for
example not just a single copy of H if
you want again many
copies of H you can tweet the hypothesis
you can tweet the proof somewhat to get
you what you want again following what
we did for the triangle counting them
question maximum degree increases this
number goes up okay I want to show you a
different way to do counting that does
not go through this embedding vertices
one by one but instead we will try to
analyze what happens if you take out an
edge of each one by one so and that's an
alternative approach which I like more
it's somewhat less intuitive if you are
not used to thinking about it but the
execution works out to be much cleaner
and it's also in line with some of the
techniques that we'll see later on when
we discuss graph limits so let's take a
quick break any questions so far
we will see a second strategy for
proving a graph counting llama and the
second strategy is more analytic in
nature which is to embed or to
analytically somehow will analyze what
happens when we take out one edge of H
okay so let me give you the statement
first the graph counting lemma says that
if you have a graph H worth vertex set
elements of 1 through K I also have an
epsilon parameter and I have a graph G
and subsets B 1 through B K G such that
VI VJ is epsilon regular whenever IJ is
an edge of H so here the setup is
slightly different from the picture I
drew up there so what's going on here is
that you have let's say H being this
graph and suppose you are in a situation
where I know that some of these
so I know that five of these pairs are
epsilon regular and what I really want
to do is embed this H into this
configuration so 1 2 B 1 B 2 and so on
and I want to know how many ways can you
embed this way the conclusion is that
the number of couples the number of such
embeddings such that the ivj is an edge
of G for all IJ h yes so we now picture
the number of such embeddings the little
VC is within a small error which is the
number of edges of H epsilon times the
total of the product of these vertex set
sizes of this number which is what you
would predict the number of embeddings
to be if all of your bipartite graphs
were actually random
so like in the triangle counting them up
if you look at the edge densities in
this configuration and predict how many
copies of H you would get that's the
number you should write down and this
counting lemma tells you that the truth
is not so far from the prediction any
questions all right so we will proof the
graph counting them up in an analytic
manner
it helps to so it will be convenient for
me to rephrase the result just a little
bit to in this probabilistic form so it
has equivalent to show that if you have
uniformly randomly chosen vertices you
little V 1 in big d 1 and so on will be
K and big be K so they're independent
uniformly at random then the probability
so basically I am putting down a
potential image for each vertex of H and
asking what's the probability that you
actually have an embedding of H so the
probability that little miracle VJ is an
actual edge of G for all IJ being an
edge of H this number here we're saying
that it differs from the prediction
which is simply multiplying all the edge
densities together so the difference
between the actual and the predicted
values is fairly small so I haven't done
anything just rephrasing the problem
instead of counting now we're looking at
probabilities as I mentioned we'll take
out one edge at a time so we blabling if
necessary let's assume that 1/2 is an
edge of H so now we'll show the
following claim so the note start that
if you look at this quantity over here
compared to if you take out just the
edge density between v1 and v2 but now
you put in a similar quantity where I'm
considering all of the edges of H except
for one two
I claim that this difference is at most
Epsilon
so you can think of this quantity here
as the same quantity as the green one
except not on H but on H minus the edge
want you to show this star claim
let us couple the two random processes
choosing these little V by that I mean
here you have the random little V ice
and here you have the random little V
ice we use the same little V ice in both
probabilities so in both there's two
different random events but you use the
same little V ice it suffices to show
this inequality star with so what's this
process this random process you pick the
one you pick B 2 you pick these three
all of them independently uniformly at
random but if I show you the inequality
under further constraint of arbitrary B
3 through VN then that's even better
so with B 3 through K fixed arbitrary
and only little V 1 and little V 2
random ok so you can phrase this in
terms of conditional probabilities if
you like so you're comparing these two
probabilities now I fix the VIII's
through the case and just let B 1 and B
2 be random and if conditioned on B 3
through VK you have this inequality then
letting V 3 through VK go letting them
be random as well by triangle inequality
you obtain the bound that we're looking
for any questions about this step if
you're confused about what's happening
here another way to bypass all the
probability languages to go back to the
counting language so in other words
we're trying to count embeddings and I'm
asking if you arbitrarily fix V 3
through VK how many different choices
are there 2 V 1 and V 2 in the two
different settings okay
so let a 1 B the set of places where
little V 1 can go if you already knew
what the 3 through VK should be
okay so you look at all the neighbors of
V one neighbors a one in H except for
two and I want to make sure that v1 VI
high ranges over all such neighbors is
indeed a valid edge in G I'll draw a
picture in a second and a two
likewise is the same quantity but was
tuned instead of one so for example if
you're in trying to embed a k4 what's
happening here is that you have this v1
plus v2 and somebody already arbitrarily
fixed the locations were v3 and v4 are
embedded and you're asking well how many
different choices are known now are now
left for me one little v1 it's the
common neighborhood of v3 and v4 so
that's your a 1 and B 3 and B 4 also
their common neighborhood in D 2 is 8
okay so with that notation what is is
that we're trying to show over here so
if you rewrite this inequality with the
b3 through the case fixed you find that
what we're trying to show is the
following so we cling and the screen
implies the start that if you look at
what the first term should be so this is
the number of edges between v1 and
between a1 and a2 as a fraction of
product of V 1 and V 2 and then the
second guy here is if you take use the
prediction D of V 1 and V 2 and so this
is each of them each of these two
factors is the probability that little V
1 lies in a one little B tootle icing a2
and then you pack on this extra constant
namely this constant yeah it's we're
trying to show that this difference is
small and the claim is that this
difference is indeed always small it's
always at most epsilon for every a 1 and
V 1 and a 2 in v2 and here in particular
so this statement looks somewhat like
the definition of epsilon regularity but
there's no restrictions on the sizes of
a 1 and a 2 they don't have to be big
and as you can imagine this statement
we're not really using all that much
we're only over assuming is the epsilon
regularity between a 1 and between B 1
and B 2 so we won't reduce this
inequality from the hypothesis of
epsilon regularity between B 1 and B 2
so let's check okay so we know that B 1
and B 2 is epsilon regular by hypothesis
so if either be either a 1 or V a 2 is
too small right so if a 1 is too small
or a 2 is too small then we see that
both of these terms here are at most
Epsilon
so if the a so too small then neither of
these terms can be too large here it's
bounded by if you took a product of a1
and a2 and likewise over there so in
this case their difference is that most
Epsilon and we're critical otherwise if
a1 and a2 are both at least an epsilon
fraction of their mbn sets then we find
that okay so what happens so here so by
by the hypothesis of epsilon regularity
we find that D of V 1 and V 2 differs
from the number of edges between a1 and
a2 divided by the product of their sizes
so that's T of a1 and a2 so this
difference is most epsilon which then
implies the inequality up there so here
we're using that size of a is at most
the size of V
all right so we have this claim and that
claim proves this inequality in star and
basically what we've done this we showed
that if you took out a single edge you
change the desired quantity by at most
Epsilon essentially so now you do this
for every edge of H alternatively you
can do induction on the number of edges
of H so to complete the proof of
accounting memo okay so we do induction
the number of edges of H and when H has
exactly one edge that's pretty easy but
now if you have more edges well you
applied induction hypothesis to the
graph which is H minus the h1 to and you
find that this quantity here differs
from
the predicted quantity by the number of
edges of H minus one times epsilon in
other words you run this proof that we
just did one edge at a time so each time
you take out an edge you use epsilon
regularity to show that the effect of
taking that edge out from H does not
have too big of an effect on the actual
number of embeddings do this for one
edge at a time and eventually you prove
the graph counting them so this is one
of those proofs which may be less
intuitive compared to the one I showed
earlier in the sense that you know
there's not as nice of a story you can
tell about putting in one vertex of time
but on the other hand if you were to
carry all this proof to bound each time
how big this says have to be it gets
much hairier over here and here the
execution is much cleaner but maybe less
intuitive unless you are willing to be
comfortable with these calculations and
it's really not so bad and the strength
of these two results are somewhat
different so again it's not so much the
exact statements that matter but the
spirit of these statements which is that
if you have a bunch of epsilon regular
pairs then you can embed and kind of
pretending that everything behaved
roughly like random questions
all right so now we have some where this
graph regularity lemma we have the graph
counting lemma embedding llamas we can
use it to derive some additional
applications that don't just involve
triangles so when we only had a triangle
counting lemma we can only do the
triangle removal lemma but now we can do
other removal emma's so in particular
there's the graph removal lemma which
generalizes the triangle removal MO okay
so in the graph removal lemma the
statement is that for every H and
epsilon there exists a delta such that
every N vertex graph with fewer than
Delta n to the vertex of H number of
copies of H so has very few copies of H
such graph can be made h3 by removing a
fairly small number of edges or it's the
same statement as the triangle removal
Emma except now for general graph H and
as you expect the proof is more or less
the same as that of a triangle removal
mo once we have the trial th counting
lemma so let me remind you how this goes
so it's really the same proof
triangle removal where there was this
recipe for applying the regularity lemma
from last time so well it's a you first
okay so what's the first step when you
do regularity you partition so let's do
partition
okay so apply the regularity lemma to do
partitioning and what's the second step
okay so we clean this graph and you do
the same cleaning procedure as in the
triangle removal amount except maybe you
have to adjust the parameter somewhat so
remove edges remove no density pairs
irregular pairs and small vertex s and
the last step okay so what do we do now
okay so you can count so if there were
any H left then the counting lemma shows
you that you must have lots of copies of
H left okay so now let me show you how
to use the strategy now that we have
this general graph counting lemma will
proof the error stone similar match
theorem which we omitted the proof that
we omitted from the first part of the
course so remind you the errors stone
romanovitch theorem says that if you
have a graph H then the extremal number
of H is equal to this quantity which
depends only on the chromatic number of
H
the lower bound comes from taking the
Turan graph you take the tour on graph
you get this lower bound so it's really
the upper bound that we need to think
about all right so what's the strategy
here the statement really is that if you
have a graph G that's n vertex whose
number of edges is at least that much
okay so I fixed an epsilon bigger than 0
fix a positive epsilon so the claim what
we're trying to show with Eddystone
small image is that if you have a graph
G with too many edges too many meaning
this many edges then G contains a copy
of H if n is sufficiently large okay so
let's use the regularity method right so
applying this three-step recipe first we
partition so partition the vertex energy
into and pieces and in such a way that
it is 8 irregular and for some parameter
theta that what decide later
the second step is cleaning the cleaning
step again the same kind of cleaning as
we've done before so let's remove an
edge from VI cross VJ if any of the
following hope the VI VJ is not 8
irregular if the density is too small or
either the two sets is too small so same
cleaning as before and we can check that
the number of edges removed is not too
small so in the first case same
calculation as last time in the same
first case number of edges removed is
that most eita and squared and we'll
choose 8 huh to be less than epsilon
over 8 actually significantly smaller as
you will see in a second in the second
step same as what happened in a triangle
removal stage the number of edges
removed in the second type is that most
that amount still very small number and
the third one here it's also a very
small number so third type they start
with one of these sets they're
impossible ok so it's very small number
and so the total
yes and most an epsilon over 2 and
squared okay so maybe I want epsilon
over yeah so okay so let's say epsilon
over 2 and squared number of edges like
that be strictly okay so now after
removing these edges from G we have this
G prime which has strictly more than 1
minus 1 over R 1 1 minus 1 over R times
and squared over 2 edges ok so now what
do we do so we knew from Tehran's
theorem that if your graph has strictly
more than this number of edges you must
have a K sub R plus 1 so even after the
meeting all these edges G still G still
has lots of edges left and in particular
Terron theorem implies that G prime
contains a click on our plus 1 vertices
so here I should say that R is chromatic
number of H minus 1 ok so I find one
copy of this clique but what does that
copy look like
I find this one copy of a click let's
say R equals to four and the point now
is that the counting lemma will allow me
to amplify that click into H so allow me
to amplify this click into a copy of H
so for example if H were this graph over
here so then you would find a copy of H
in G which is what we want so why does
the counting lemma allow you to do this
amplification so it's at this point the
ideas are all there but there's there's
a slight wrinkle in the calculations I
mean there's in the executions I just
want to point out just in case some of
the vertices of H end up in the same
vertex in G but that turns out not to be
an issue so by counting lemma the number
R comma morphisms from H to G prime
where I'm really only considering
homomorphisms that map each vertex and H
2 is a sine part is at least this
quantity where I'm looking at the
predicted density of such homomorphisms
and all of these edge densities are at
least epsilon over 8 so it's at least
that amount minus a small error that
comes from the counting
and well all of the vertex parts are
quite large so all of the vertex parts
are of size like that so that's the
result of the counting lemma combined
with information about the densities of
the parts and the sizes of the parts
that came out of cleaning so setting
eita
to be an appropriate value we see that
for sufficiently large and this quantity
here is on the order of and - the number
of vertices of H but I'm only counting
homomorphisms and so it could be that
some of the vertices of H end up in the
same vertex of G and those would not be
genuine sub graphs so I shouldn't
consider those as sub graphs because
otherwise if you were to allow those
then if you found this k4 then you found
all four chromatic graphs so you
shouldn't consider copies that are
degenerate but that's okay because the
number of maps from the vertex set of H
to the vertex set of G that are non
injective is of a lower water the number
of non injective maps from the vertex
set well you have to pick two vertices
of H to map to the same vertex and then
the number of choices you have one order
less so there are a negligible fraction
of these homomorphisms and the
conclusion then is that G prime contains
a copy of H which is what we're looking
for G prime contains copy of H then G
contains a copy of H and that
the area stone Shimano veteran you get a
bit more out of this proof so you see
that not only does G contain one copy of
H but the counting lemma actually shows
you it contains many copies of H and
this is a phenomenon known as super
saturation which you already saw in the
first problem set that often when you
are beyond a certain threshold an
extremal threshold you don't just gain
one extra copy but you often gain many
copies and it's you see this in this
proof here okay so to summarize we've
seen this proof of errors strong Chimel
image which comes from applying
regularity and then finding a single
copy of a clique from Tehran's theorem
and then using counting lemma to boost
that copy from Tehran's theorem into an
actual copy of H so in the second
homework one of the problems is to come
up with a different proof of Adderstone
small image that is more similar to the
proof of cavora shorter on more through
double counting like arguments and that
is closer in spirit although not exactly
the same as the original proof in stone
so this regularity proof I think it's
more conceptual you get to see how to do
this boosting but it gives you a
terrible bound and the other proof that
you see in the homework gives you a much
more reasonable bound on the dependence
between how engross versus how quickly
this little ol has to go to zero